this is such a famous story when did you
first hear there's two of the most
famous women in history and the synergy
of their lives their parallel lives yes
it's in our childhoods I'm British
English as you can probably know so yeah
so it's a big part of our upbringing I
guess that I first came across him in
detail when I was directing Shakespeare
plays in my career so when I first
started to work at the Royal Shakespeare
Company that caused me to delve a bit
more deeply into British history and I
first started to really think hard about
these two women and for the biggest
decision that you would have had to make
apart from saying yes to directing it it
had to be the casting how did that come
about and you had to have lightning in a
bottle with these two women yeah they're
extraordinary aren't they I mean I'm so
so lucky to have them both and one of
the things that brought me onto the
project is that it was offered to me
with Saoirse attached to it
so Saoirse Ronan was 23 when she sort of
shot the film you've just seen she's
signed on to play Mary Queen of Scots
when she was 18 years old and she kept
the faith with wanting to portray that
Queen for lots of very deep quite
personal reasons actually that over the
course of those five six years that she
waited to play that part matured within
her as she matured as an actor in front
of her eyes you know on cinema screens
so it was it was Saoirse and a desire to
work with her that drew me to it
Lady Bird wasn't out at that point but I
seen a city was a little girl and that
extraordinary performance in Brooklyn
and we got together with the producers
and they said who do you want to play
Elizabeth the first it was a bit of a
longer journey because the version of
the story I had originally did not have
Elizabeth in it so he got beau Willimon
to write as a new screenplay and the
Brezza said who did I want to play
Elizabeth the first
and I said Margot Robbie and they said
okay well good luck go and see if he
could persuade her so I flew out to Los
Angeles which is a town really I'm only
just beginning to get to know
Kasturi is my background this is my
first movie first anything on screen and
sat down with Margo and she was about 45
minutes from going on her honeymoon the
last thing she said to me was I've
really got to go in pack but this has
been great and and we sat together and
spoke about the role and initially she
said no why was that because like many
great actors as well as searing talent
she has extraordinary humility and she
was very aware that this is a role as
you alluded to initially that has been
played by many great women on film
particularly before so Cate Blanchett is
her hero
she knew that Judi Dench whom I've
worked with had played Helen Mirren him
I would have played it Harriet Walter
who might you know I've worked with a
lot of Elizabeth's over the years and
you know I think as I said to her that
gives me a kind of an ability to spot an
Elizabeth and so I got back home to
London and a bit like in the movie wrote
her this passionate letter that said
here's why I think you should do this
and here's how as someone who spent
their career up into this point working
with actors in great detail I can get
you ready and prepare you for that part
and thank goodness she said yes and this
is as you say it's a role that's been
both of these our roles have been played
before Sarah Bernhardt played Queen
Elizabeth yeah at one point
so what Katharine Hepburn played Mary on
film as well there's an extraordinary
cinematic tradition of it in fact the
first special effect ever committed to
film is a little silent movie at the ABA
of the execution of Mary Queen of Scots
so it's something that's always
fascinated cinema I mean I guess we feel
like maybe we've not seen Mary's story
as that being the powering narrative for
quite a long time
the production design was interesting
because it was very realistic it was
shot and you can talk about some of the
locations but it also had this great
stylized sense to it from the woman's
hair to the fact that you made the
decision to put the men all in black at
a time when men were the peacocks more
than yeah you talked about how you
wanted it to look with especially trying
to blend those two elements which is
difficult yes so I mean let's start with
the man
so this period of history you're right
there were peacocks was all about the
male leg so and what was slightly above
it yeah well yes orbit yes absolutely I
did me us a comment
I'm very English about that kind of
thing but but but man would show off
their legs and they would wear what we
call tights in England you would call
kind of pantyhose
and they were they kind of sort of
equivalent of little shorts kind of
micro mini says puffy pants
cela seen in pictures and um Alex Byrne
who also designed the costumes for
Elizabeth and Elizabeth Golden Age which
she was recognized by the Academy was
very aware that and I don't know I don't
know if their acts in the room I don't
have to put this up politely because
this may sound cruel and savage but not
all men's legs can take its height or
take advantage it's quite it's actually
quite it's a good lesson for them to
learn after all listen I'm not sure mine
can so this is not a gender specific
thing but and actually that that can
make them incredibly self-conscious and
what we wanted to do was to give them a
kind of confidence and virility and also
to in Alex's vision for it put them in
in a kind of fabric and clothes that
actually would take on kind of pattern
ER and texture so you'll see that
assertions the hem of searchers dress
takes in water or dirt in a poetic sense
that that pattern that's created grows
from a pattern in the dirt or in the
water so you get this sense that
actually this essentially French Queen
because she's been raised in France is
becoming part of Scotland I'm beginning
to understand her country in a poetic
way and all the searchers costumes in
the movie as the men's costumes are made
of denim which doesn't necessarily read
on screen I think but that allowed Alex
to do two things one of which is that
she could make absolutely everything so
every costume that you see on that
screen she has designed and made because
it's a cheap fabric and it gave her the
ability to work in it it also gives you
this fabric that actually acts as a
comfortable living in not so that women
are very corseted so
now slightly but I'm not very
put-together and held in but with the
men particularly it gave them a kind of
sexiness and a confidence and a
familiarity in those clothes that really
allowed them to feel and breathing the
character so it kind of came from that
and it has a body to it that you know
it's almost like armor in a way I can
feel yeah when they ride horses it kind
of marks between the legs and you can
sort of see that so it gets a kind of
money my granny in the north of England
was always obsessed with cowboy movies
and it's got that slight quality to it I
think they did so much horse riding how
did they deal with each other on set did
you want to keep them apart or did you
want them to when they were together to
be their characters and not themselves
said we rehearsed for two weeks which
was incredibly helpful but that big
scene that they play in the forest
cottage as we call it the barn really
the washhouse
we contrived to keep them apart for the
entire day in which we shot it
so when Saoirse pulls down that curtain
and they look at each other and we could
run two cameras and catch both their
close-ups in that moment they are
looking at each other in costume and the
character for the first time and it has
something of the documentary about at
that moment I think as well as something
of the fictional because the visceral
shock and they both say that the emotion
that they experienced in that moment
what happened is not what they imagined
would happen and I think that was partly
the intensity of the exercise of keeping
them apart it was partly because and you
know look I know we all know that social
is extraordinary that was her first day
on the film when we shot that scene it
was Margo's last day and searches first
day yeah I know incredible right I mean
she has been preparing since she's 18
years old so as a theater director by
trade I can get her to some extent ready
for that scene but when she pulls down
that curtain and confronts a woman who
is the only person in the world who can
understand what it is like to be her and
also will be her executioner that was
understandably quite intense and one
take yeah that's the first take yeah it
struck me as I was watching that one of
the reasons that this these characters
have been portrayed and interpreted
again and again
so few big roles for women from history
and to this day we're struggling to do
that how did that sit in your mind as
you were thinking about this and what
women or anybody in the audience might
take away from this film because you
don't want it to be a story told in
amber and locked and frozen you want it
to be vital for today do you know what
makes me cross can I be a little bit
cross yeah what makes me cross is when
people say oh why are they doing
Elizabeth and Mary Queen of Scots again
and you go when do we hear people say oh
why are they doing Hamlet again like you
don't you don't hear that there's no
sense when men get to play these
gigantic roles they're actually he it's
not like how wondrous now we have one of
our one of our great actors giving us
their Hamlet like for me Margot Robbie
is giving us her Elizabeth and Saoirse
Ronan is giving us her Mary Queen of
Scots and do you know what like a decade
from now somebody else incredible will
do it but we we need to be able to have
for these women not only these new roles
and these fresh things and form Argos go
let's put Tonya Harding on Phil you know
what we also need is to be able to allow
women to follow in the footsteps of
other great women that have gone before
them and to have that sense of lineage
and so every every version of this
speaks to the generation that's being
made in and for I think so yeah I mean
and also I think we all know don't we
that you make a film and we think it's a
period drama and then 20 years later you
look at it and you go wow that looks
exactly like the 1990s yeah that looks
exactly like the 1917 like we trick
ourselves if we think that we're not
producing the present into the past in
order to tell ourselves new stories and
this you know the most amazing thing
about getting to work on film is it is
the great storytelling medium like I
realized that now theatres this is a
different thing right theatres about
intimacy and it's about exchange of air
right it's about we're all in this room
right and the city is telling itself
this story today the the flicker and
beauty and gorgeousness of there
to me and its ability to Weaver story is
so incredible I think because it has the
most close focus on an actor and you're
capturing something with these two
incredible young women that is fugitive
you know when someone does this story
again a decade's time people will look
back and go oh my God look at Saoirse
Ronan when she was doing this
extraordinary thing at 23 years of age
look at Margot Robbie look at what
they've done in the subsequent decade
like this is a big moment for both of
them I think so what would you like
people to take away when they pick up
their coats and no not here no coats
here leave the theater yeah there are no
codes from absolutely marvelous so many
great things about Los Angeles but yeah
the lack of coats is great um I think I
think I really want them to think about
those two actors I think it was Saoirse
who pulled me into this the idea of this
creature that we have who is so
incredible and who's making cinema right
now and I think I want them to feel not
in a patronizing way but the pride that
I feel in Margo for actually having the
humility to say no and having the
courage to say yes and I want them to
take those performances away with them
because I feel that's what we really
retain from from films isn't it we take
the actors away you remember Rosalind
Russell and Katharine Hepburn I do
please thank Josie work